but uh i was kind of arguing for lebron
with rap
and he goes dude you know i know
basketball players some of my best
friends he goes you know what the common
theme amongst all the mario what he goes
he's the fakest dude in the league
lebron's listening to this
i don't give a [ __ ] all right well i do
brian what they saying about you brother
don't listen to the negativity i don't i
don't judge anybody tying me to myself
you don't like the ellen [ __ ] or anyone
like you listen everyone has their
opinions of
certain people but until i have a
one-on-one encounter i used like dang
cook
a lot of comics on dane cook dane cook
has always been fantastic
but you also got to realize people might
treat you differently yeah because you
can fight
not cause you can fight but just like
you know you're a little bit more known
and all this stuff blah blah blah
you too famous brittany i am not that
man are you crazy the grand scheme of
things
not that you mean bro have you seen your
instagram comments
famous i have it oh yeah you don't read
it right let me just say you got bots
underneath your comment section now
i didn't know it was a box yeah bro i
didn't know it was a bot it was like a
girl was like uh you know i didn't know
like it's
like some porn ads and it was a girl
that commented underneath it was a box
she was like
i'm hot but no one cares i was like
should i do
[Applause]
cat always has to deal with it
how do those sometimes sometimes i'll do
a show i'm like ugh catching me dealing
with the backlash from this one
i gave a hot take on refs the other day
i'm below the bell i'm like i feel bad
for kevin
sometimes i wake up and i'm like [ __ ]
i'll get kind of heads up though i'm
like get ready for tomorrow
damn dawg that's so crazy well [ __ ] you
got him now you famous yeah
yeah it's all fame is all relative right
how do you deal with me
what do you mean bro i i listen i'm not
first of all i'm not like
bro if you you can recognize rogan's
famous okay
yeah there's different levels brogan's
famous yeah logan's famous fake
when rogan did the spotify deal you know
i mean theo were talking about
he went from like famous amongst
comedians and like
the podcast circle to like mainstream
that's a different i don't and i don't
know if we're built for that i don't
know you know the
crazy [ __ ] we say and stuff like that if
it's taken out of context
when you go from this world to the real
famous world
dude it's a different level now he's
built for it his armor
you know he's built for it but i i
wouldn't want that
you wouldn't want that no i don't think
i could deal with it i want i
want a bank account but again yeah same
thing with the bro that's why i don't
judge
till i meet him but with lebron you're
talking about different different level
dude
that's a different level of thing bro i
got famous yesterday i don't need to be
that famous
what did you say that's it i felt like i
was on a high i had a chainsaw yesterday
and a lot of that right now bro yeah a
lot of agents was in my dms it's like
malik talk your [ __ ]
talk your [ __ ] bro i didn't know how to
celebrate so i just watched all the rush
hours
okay oh there you go why not i had the
support the apple store is closed then
somebody would go
like like look like look at catwoman
famous as [ __ ] went crazy is he crazy
though
i mean that one video of him fighting
that seventh grader is pretty funny
though well he lost too
yeah oh my god that was so funny he's
got a [ __ ]
a seventh grader
bro how are you still on the seventh
grade
is that video still exists i'm sure or
his team got it all taken
down like he went crazy in like seattle
remembers like on the streets
there was something that happened crazy
in phoenix too he was doing a show oh he
went off on
some mexican dude about mexico or
something like that really yeah it was
like a big thing
he now could just be he's just crazy
from the jump and then we just get to
see it because he's famous but that's
true i don't think you just can't help
yeah because who or who gets into a kid
over a soccer game
it was over a soccer ball i'm soccer i
swear to god i remember that but he's so
short that seventh grader was like
[ __ ] yeah like he's not gonna do it
like grown man he's like all right
whatever i'm talking about what's so
funny is
around recording this try to record it
like a regular he pulled up who pulls up
like a regular school
fight like they all got inserted like
fight fight fighting catwoman's like
yeah [ __ ] i know you're here
you just hear me not to hear me
and then they fought and then he lost
sitting there wrestling around in the
grass you know and the great he was
wrestling dog
wrestling it was like it got so bad that
was like man that cat up yeah
come on man check it out oh man you know
you got a
netflix special and they're young they
don't know
they don't appreciate that's so
insulting they didn't know his name let
money mike up the dude from friday at
the next how tall has been how tall is
catwoman he's short yeah
super short monster of comedian shout
out to a monster
yeah he's a beast a monster he's a beast
though some of his specials top five
undeniable five five and that's
wikipedia five five five one of the
goats bro killed it on wild enough
nobody killed it
nobody wanted to touch him in that wild
style with him he was always the best of
the wild style
killed it come on bro dude i almost
tried to get a perm until you have that
video
chin walling
[Music]
god please bruh oh right here right here
bruh this is him just
look how he's rolled up just you have to
fast forward a little bit
well first of all the kid's bigger than
him no that's not him that's not the guy
it's a black guy
he said no i'm talking for real yeah oh
gee let him know cat
let him know
the [ __ ] out what's up i told you
oh he beat he beat that ass they're like
that
just just out of respect how can you i
don't care what cat william said i just
out of respect how does that happen
how does that happen why would he steal
on that little dude and he was like
what's up
didn't he look he don't let him up
that's how he did hit him first
he yeah he did yeah that's what i'm
saying no but i'm just like yeah what
are you gonna do
here's my thing you're just not in the
right frame of mind state of mind to hit
a seventh grader yeah you're gonna still
buy his hair you're working
don't say anything to me in the world
that i would never get you know so funny
he didn't even get canceled for that
no yeah that's right no one gave a [ __ ]
you know i'm sorry for him
yeah you never met a man i don't know if
i have to go down bums me out that's
what that does that
bumps me up can you imagine if dave
chappelle got a schoolyard fight with
the seventh grade
and
sometimes when i watch world star i
watch i get on world star
multiple times a day you're addicted to
it i love it but when there's fights on
there i'll watch i'm like damn
that dude had a little bit of training
you could have a career don't worry
that's how i stop stop doing that
get in the gym you might have a career
every hood do got the same stance
every every all the way usually it's
wide and just like
which one you're like this yeah there
you go and usually why there you go get
them g
yeah get them yeah get them hey i
thought about you with the nunchucks
like how would you fight a hood dude
with the nunchucks
that'll scare the hell out of the hood
dude that's why they wouldn't even fight
if you pull out numbers
stop with that karate [ __ ] because they
don't know dude got scared bro he was
like i'm cool
i'd be terrified yeah come on numb
chucks in a backflip like oh
[ __ ] you you are you call a power ranger
i am a unicorn or you're a power ranger
yeah i'm not a power ranger would you
wouldn't do a power rangers
i love pogba had me in that ugly ass
suit bro put me in that bruce lee outfit
you're gonna
die you're on a diet
are they ready to fight they're ready
all right all right hello let me switch
over to my morphing watch to my calorie
watch
i just count my watch or whatever the
hell they call it
yeah whoop that trick boom get him
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song